ma il frutto di un secondo ago ma
signori sto per fare un esperimento
rivoluzionario sudore che si vuole di
caldo si muore di caldo in questi giorni
ma anche una roba l'arrivo dell'estate
io ti vedo nel vivo delle l'arrivo
dell'estate si sente e tutti abbiamo
bisogno di un pochino di fresco ma
questa diretta in st paolina degli
aironi ecco perché oggi proveremo a fare
un condizionatore home made low budget e
musica assume acqua sembrano sudato a
questa faccia sempre sera sulla
maglietta forse alla grande è fatto in
casa nella tua abitazione dimora mail
astenetevi pure se avete già un
condizionatore tutto a soli 30 euro si
può arrivare questo esperimento si è
tenuta guardando il tutorial di simone
ornati vi lasciamo il suo link giù in
descrizione anche se non avremo con più
stile simone quarta l'occhio per fare un
condizionatore è fatto in casa avremo
bisogno di un occhio che devi guardare
simone fogli di polistirolo un
contenitore bello grosso come piacciono
a noi una ventola colla a caldo un
pennarello
roba per tagliare numerose bottiglie di
acqua gelata e una canna fumaria guarda
l'occhio simone la prima cosa dovremo
fare sarà quella di aprire la scatola
con dentro
e foderare tutto quanto l'interno con il
polistirolo
io non so prendere le misure pensano
però possiamo chiamare si muove in cui
vive chiamatemi simone anzi scrive di
tutti questi quel punto guarda negli
occhi e simone è andati pure sul video
di simone scrivete simone guarda lacchia
di guglielmo questa pseudo precisione
ricordatelo sempre infatti un uso pure
la destra che mancano abbiamo però me lo
fa apposta che lo fai dall'alto dove non
è la camera è un atm gay ed etero e di
stimolare italiano questo lo faccio per
complice tanto le super morbide e alla
fine dovremo avere più o meno questo il
momento della vita
mamma mia james earl colla a caldo
attacchiamo la è una scena inguardabile
non guardare che dio ci si muovono
simone mi sento sapete com'è cioè
piccolo ingegneri che deve guardare il
mio no non dire non è perfetto ma il gol
è retto solo monego perché se i
tagliandi un lato drizzò fi che il tema
minieri coperti come fratello simone
viene meglio secondo per linate di de
simone
prendo questo qui si muore
diventerebbero equa chi però prima di
tagli in un castello ce li fa passare la
canna fumaria
certo poi tema prima in italia e poi
però se comunque un'arma ma ancora di
più freddi anarchico grazie per queste
cose sempre pseudo precisione dire
sempre simone subito quello prima taglia
la plastica e di facile e cioè anarchia
allo stato puro ragazzi e di forare
questo coperta sulla trama io però
vorrei mettere questo momento è quello
di sopra così che l'aria passa
attraverso le bottiglie la linea medio
sai come la parte finora da un
ventilatore norme anche delle già stato
qui è la canna fumaria la messa sempre
sopra cui abbattuto sul coperchio lato
anarchia invece cosa di mettere questo
qui dalla canna fumaria la può fare
anche dalla plateau ma qui stiamo
creando un piccolo elefantino bellissimo
guarda in pari le facciamo il segno
benvenuti nella mia cucina sto
riscaldandola me è in genere il call di
letame non fatelo a casa ma se sto cosa
non funziona se volete vengo cerca casa
simona in realtà non fa vedere che
procedimento simone comincia il video
che c'è già la cassa pronta simone in
giro
quando adesso un ambiente altamente
nociva vediamo un po che siamo accedere
alla specie salto in bagno forse
dobbiamo verificare se c'è un
abbassamento di temperatura no brucia il
salone lo studio aperti non sono stato
in studio pride enrico è stato veramente
di cattivo gusto che cosa troppo tutta
sul mio come ok ragazzi ma invece
l'imprenditore è uno dei campionamenti
la fredda che guardate lo strumento
andiamo a prendere il calco in cucina il
polistirolo gli faccio anche le orecchie
il nostro dumbo che tira fuori aria
fredda il nostro duro a occhio che
comunque è la fiera il fatto a capri
cannes e che poi io vivo a 32 anni ma io
posso metterla fatto una cucina
rischiando di morire come nei fumi
tossici proprio vero che ero più va
avanti e più cresce la verde tocca il
che è molto socratico come pensiero ma
sai cosa diceva solo no perché non ho
capito niente della vita persa perché
non sapere soldi non sapevo di non
sapere al sacrario di giava da aponte ci
siamo ragazzi bellissimo bellissimo
questo da buttare qualche mio occhio si
muovono giro regaliamo alla fine ha
tanto vediamo se esce un qualcosa di
sensato altra ragione deve essere un
disperato per godere di una bella sì se
ne gli sperati volete un tumblr scrivete
qua sotto foglio tour
dovete essere iscritti al mio cane su
youtube aia profilo su instagram che il
nostro uguale tutto
guarda il nocciolo si pone in questo
momento sarebbe cosa mi sento il padre
di bel tour
bellissimo si vede c'è certo bellissimo
giorno ed ombre e arrabbiato è un jumbo
che si fanno per tutto quello che ha
passato la di segnali già non so cosa
sto facendo e resistono idea di cosa sto
parlando
comunque devo dire che hai un futuro
come nulla appassionati affrettati che
fosse un complimento del team e super
multa
io penso che in questo momento tu sia
guardando l'occhio di simone
arrabbiatissimo solo che c'è questo
cavolo di scolo vabbè velo tornerete a
casa per inizi dentro c'è
guardo il mio occhio simone il dietro
inter lo normale ma nuova ventola nolana
per la ventola minimi facciano una
piazzola guglielmo montale d'azione
proprio becera dai lui e vai a
carreggiate zampe sono le ruote di un
bellissimo dove della pelle rimessi
d'apertura
è una visione piacevole allora infiliamo
in astratto dove come bloccare la
ventola non apprezzate la stessa
tonalità dell'anno nella proposta
grazie in una parola classe ragazzi sono
nè questo anno è troppo piccolo c'è
bisogna imparare non può farlo ma se io
mi sia sfuggito roteando america è una
scena bruttissima potevo sbloccato bravo
appena messo stores mettiamo il lato
d'ombra gli faccio canestro devo fare un
altro d'ombra nell'altro lato arrivi
anche di un brivido non era male il suo
vero nome di un brivido mesi ed un
bellissimo ragazzi bellissimo ma quello
che prefissato a creare contenuti così
pazzeschi e siamo quasi alla fine
mettete orecchie coperchio tutto
creazione del coperchio sul film
qualcosa ad un brivido di un brivido
figlio di scavino come si diceva
proprietà di cui dovranno mettere loro
nome in modo che se lo perdono sanno a
chi li istituirlo parte al mare l'evento
con l'attacco per la macchina avuto un
brivido funziona anche la ghiacciaia c'è
tutto vietato puoi mettere anche le cose
dirigente dal naso
a ben guardare
vado rotolare verso le orecchie quasi
così si rovina colori che lo sapete ma
prima di tutto questo ed un brivido
possa fare impresa cinematografica
[Musica]
a questo punto procuratevi sette
bottiglie d'acqua ghiacciata in realtà
faccia freddo così cioè io sto crepando
rifreddo la relazione tra queste
bottiglie le prendiamo le infiliamo
dentro 347 vietato pesantuccio s
aria fredda ok è vero posso dire che i
furori e aria condizionata e o di
obbligo di polistirolo serve a mantenere
la temperatura
davvero ho detto io vai a fare un
esperimento ragazzi ci mettiamo nella
stanza più piccola di dieci minuti nel
frattempo noi siamo un ordine e poi
torniamo in bagno da d'un brillo ok
qual è allora vai proviamo e nicotina e
shorts da allora non abbiamo un
termometro ma abbiamo
la nostra pelle ragazzi la sentire
questa temperatura e io non memorizzata
attivava ciao con brivido ci vediamo fra
poco
ciao ciao centro cuore starà male da
solo sentitelo sta piangendo piccolo
resoconto sull'attività reperibilità dei
materiali gianmarco un conto ci ha messo
più o meno venti minuti materiali facili
a trovare esecuzione facile da eseguire
funzionalità non scoprirono breve
ragazze comunque è una cazzata da fare
in realtà sembra una cosa assurda ma ad
un brivido sarà legato sono uno di voi e
non sei tu simone dopo mezz'ora io mi
aspetto la botta di fresco se non ce la
fate rifresco pallone da un calcio ad un
brick entra ragazzi c'è fresco fanno
sentire sia abbassata di un paio di
gradi secondo me di 34 tu lo sai che si
tu no ma è ricorsa in un secondo me non
è cambiato da quando nel paio degli
uomini esci fuori ti fa fare sconti
poetare è più fresco dillo è più fresco
lo merito è stato pagato per tratta di
brivido funziona e possiamo dirlo
attende una cosa padrone
guardatevi il carino mi chiamo qualcosa
[Risate]
no no no no poi si perde dentro la 21
doveva essere il più potente dei ragazzi
io e un brivido vi salutiamo sapere che
se lo volete adottare da di scrivere tra
i commenti voglio essere iscritte il mio
canale seguirmi su instagram
detto ciò che altro dire a carta dire
alla prossima se volete che tu un livido
travi la felicità che cos'è questo un
pezzo di colla e non perde di un brivido
cadendo a pezzi
noi ci vediamo domenica alle 12 con un
nuovo cucina buttata ciao